hey what's up you
crazy i'm gonna call you guys pimps but
that doesn't even make sense i have been
attempting to pack to go home for my
family vacation it's the
uh yeah annual family vacation in north
carolina whoa i know you guys are
probably sick of me talking about
traveling but let's just talk about
packing i am so bad at packing clothes
unbelievable i went to new york for
two total days i packed
13 pairs of shoes
how many pairs did i wear one one pair
maybe two per i need two per give me two
pair i'll move stuff under my ear
now packing too much is a problem in
itself but my problem is procrastination
right now you guys can't see it i
actually had to stand up today because
if i showed you what my floor looked
like well i'm going to show it to you
anyway this is how
i attempt to pack i start putting things
in little piles i've got my tank tops
i've got my bathing suits i've got my
jeans i've got my leggings i've got my
socks i've got my underwear i've got my
bras i've got t-shirts i've got the
workout t-shirts i've got the workout
pants i've got the sweatpants that i'm
going to sleep in let's not forget the
shirts that i plan on sleeping and they
all have their own little piles now it
may look like a complete mess but i'm a
little ocd when it comes to putting
everything in and actually packing it
just takes me a while i get a little
sidetracked gonna play some video games
for a minute and then go back to packing
i'm hungry to make a snack it just goes
on and on pretty much until i have to
get up at 6am and realize that i have
nothing packed
[Music]
taxi is calling me and asking why i'm
not outside yet i was like hold on sir
please sir just they leave they leave
i'm gonna leave me stranded leave me
stranded why because i'm too busy
packing like an idiot it's so terrible
anyway i look forward to vlogging with
you guys at the beach this uh family
vacation we didn't go last year but
we're going again this year so if you
happen to be vacationing in the outer
banks perhaps i will see your smiling
faces and until then well don't know
that's all i got i've gotta actually go
finish packing now peace out
[Music]
i've always feel free that i'm not
recording
[Music]